maría tiene 70 páginas en su libreta
ella ha hecho una gráfica sobre los
distintos tipos de escritos que ha
estado trabajando cuántas páginas vacías
quedan en la libreta de mariah y bien
acá abajo
tengo una gráfica de dibujos o
pictogramas que nos muestra todas las
páginas que maría ha usado de su libreta
pero nos preguntan cuántas páginas
vacías quedan en la libreta de mariah
así que para obtener la respuesta lo
primero que tenemos que tomar en cuenta
es cuántas páginas teníamos en un inicio
lo cual nos lo dicen justo aquí maría
tiene 70 páginas en su libreta entonces
a estas 70 páginas vamos a quitarle la
cantidad de páginas que maría ya utilizó
entonces a esto le vamos a quitar le
vamos a quitar la cantidad de bocas que
ella
estado trabajando la cantidad de hojas
que ella ha estado trabajando y como
respuesta vamos a obtener la cantidad de
hojas vacías que quedan en la libreta de
mariah que es justo lo que queremos
entonces la pregunta ahora es cuántas
páginas ha estado trabajando porque con
esa información voy a poder obtener mi
respuesta bueno todavía no lo sabemos
pero este pictograma nos va a ayudar a
encontrar la respuesta bien lo primero
que quiero que observes y que es muy
importante es esta información de aquí
que me dice que cada una de estas
páginas de papel equivale a dos páginas
de su libreta
entonces para los poemas ella ha usado
dos páginas y otras dos páginas así que
en total haya usado cuatro páginas para
los poemas para los reportes ella ha
usado dos cuatro seis ocho diez páginas
para los reportes para las historias
ella ha usado 2 4 6 8 10 12 14 páginas
para las historias también ha escrito
cartas y para las cartas ha usado 2 468
hojas y por último también escribe un
diario y en ese diario ha gastado 2 4 6
8 10 12 páginas de su libreta
este es el total de páginas que ella ha
usado de su libreta podemos sumar todas
estas cantidades las cuatro páginas para
poemas las diez páginas para reportes y
todas las demás y eso nos dará el número
total de páginas que ella ha estado
trabajando hasta ahora y después esa
cantidad la podemos sustituir justo aquí
y podemos decir si a 70 páginas con las
que empezó le quitamos esta cantidad
obtendremos así nuestra solución final
de las páginas que le sobran de las
páginas que tiene vacías en su libreta
así que vamos a encontrar este total y
para eso vamos a sumar estas cantidades
las cuatro páginas que utilizó para
poemas más las diez páginas que utilizo
para reportes
las 14 páginas que utilizo para
historias
más las ocho páginas que utilizo para
las cartas y por último le vamos a sumar
las doce páginas de su diario muy bien y
habrá que sumar todas estas cantidades
así que si empezamos a sumar las
unidades
tenemos 2 + 8 lo cual es 10 10 + 4 es 14
14 + 0
bueno se mantienen 14 y 14 4 es 18 18
ya esto le voy a sumar y ahora vamos a
fijarnos en las decenas tengo una vez
diez más
otra vez diez eso me da dos veces diez o
veinte más otra vez diez
eso me da tres veces diez o treinta
entonces me va a quedar 18 más 30
lo cual es exactamente igual a 48 48
páginas ha usado esta maria de su
libreta y ahora si ponemos este número
por aquí vamos a poder obtener la
cantidad de páginas vacías que le quedan
a la libreta de mariah y bueno si le
quitamos estas 48 páginas a las 70
páginas iniciales nos va a dar el número
de páginas que restan sin usar bien una
forma de hacer esto es contar desde 48
hasta 70 si vamos de 48 a 50 vamos a
sumar dos páginas muy bien hay dos
páginas vacías y después de 50 a 70 hay
20 páginas más entonces dos páginas
vacías para llegar a las 50 páginas y 20
más para llegar a las 70 páginas y ahora
sí si sumamos estos dos me va a dar la
cantidad de páginas vacías que tiene
maría 22
páginas sin usar tienen todavía la
libreta de maría